[Music]
cars today can be controlled from an app
their ai assistant can help you find the
best routes
some even have cameras that detect
whether you're too tired to drive
those high-tech features also mean cars
are gathering a lot of data about us
vehicles can collect up to several
terabytes per hour which can be used to
train algorithms and help innovation
in china that's caught the government's
attention they realize data has national
security as well as economic attributes
they need to
have their hands on them
so after it announced strict data
regulations on e-commerce and other tech
companies prompting a sell-off of many
chinese stocks this summer
china's setting new rules for the auto
industry this time it's directly
affecting foreign car makers tesla in
particular tesla will work with national
authorities in all countries to ensure
data security on intelligent and
connected vehicles if you're a foreign
company in china you increasingly need
to walk a high wire act
tesla and others will be required to
store a lot of data for example about
traffic flow and charging stations
inside china
some automakers including tesla has so
they're prepared to do that
but cyber security analysts say
authorities could now also ask companies
to share that user data changing the
game in the world's largest auto market
i'm very confident that the future in
china is going to be great
for many global car brands china's been
the most important growth market in
recent years last year alone more than
138 000 model 3s were sold there that's
more than one-third of global sales for
that model and elon musk is determined
to expand further china i think long
term will be
our biggest market but both where we
make the most number of vehicles and
where we have the most number of
customers but auto analysts point out
that those growth opportunities hinge on
the government's goodwill i want to very
much
say thank you and appreciation for the
shanghai government and the support and
tesla is particularly exposed the
american company's cars rely a lot on
software and its model 3 was the best
selling ev in china last year china has
already restricted military staff and
employees of key state-owned companies
from using tesla cars for fear of data
leaks according to people familiar with
the matter
tesla declined to comment
in the past few months we've essentially
seen a regulatory storm sam sachs is a
senior fellow at yale law school she's
been researching china's cyber security
policy for about a decade foreign
automakers they're gonna have to walk
this dance between beijing and dc and
it's a high wire act navigating between
pressure from washington around
decoupling with china as well as
increased pressure from beijing
as tensions between china and the us
have grown in recent years companies
handling data have been caught in the
crosshairs in the u.s tech firms
including tick tock and huawei have been
targeted by government measures while in
china
officials have stopped what was supposed
to be the world's biggest ipo by fintech
giant ant and have also stepped up
control of tech companies including
social media conglomerate tencent and
ride hailing giant deedee
was investigated over national security
concerns shortly after listed in new
york sinking the company's stock value
deity said it would fully cooperate with
the review they fall under this broader
umbrella of the party tightening control
the party is trying to make the private
sector better align and carry out its
vision
so what do international car companies
have to do after october 1st when these
rules go into effect
tesla said it set up data centers in
china to store locally all data
generated by vehicles there these new
auto data rules are a game changer
because it says
look the operating environment is
changing
while the requirements aren't really a
surprise since china laid out plans to
increase control of data in a 2017 cyber
security law analysts say from now on
companies like tesla could be asked to
share private data with local
authorities once foreign car makers
moved to store data locally they lost a
lot of control
yes companies very often do push back on
demands by the chinese government to
access the data but the space to do that
has been shrinking
i think in part because of the spate of
new regulations that show the government
is prioritizing this data as very
sensitive to national security and the
definition of national security is broad
according to the new rules any
information regarding military and
government locations and logistics data
traffic or charging stations for
electric vehicles for example is deemed
sensitive and alsa could be requested by
the government
china's cyber security authority didn't
respond to our request seeking comment
tesla also didn't respond to our
questions about how it would handle any
such requests from authorities
elon musk recently said his company
would address data security concerns
data security is not only the
responsibility of a single company
but also the cornerstone
of the whole industry development we
also asked several foreign car makers
including ford bmw and others how they
would handle such requests but they
didn't respond
tighter rules in china are also expected
to affect how companies work remember
those algorithms that improve your car's
features they may be harder to develop
for foreign automakers if data collected
in china has to stay in china and can't
be easily transferred to research and
development centers around the world if
data has to transfer outside of china
then it has to go through a very
specific security check process xiaoming
liu researches data governance she says
separating data for single countries
means companies may end up working on
some technologies twice or in parallel
in two different places this is a major
challenge to their business model this
is very costly this is not
economical this is the opposite of the
most economical model
tesla and other automakers didn't
respond to our questions about whether
this would impact innovation
so far investors have largely shrugged
off the changes as beijing's new rules
come into effect stocks of tesla daimler
and other automakers popular in china
have actually done pretty well as demand
recovers from its lows during the
pandemic in part that's because the data
affected by changes in china only
represents one part of foreign
automakers as overall business
and industry analysts point out that the
chinese market is simply too important
for many companies not to comply this is
a bellwether of what's to come if you're
a company and you're not in the auto
sector but you handle a lot of data this
regulation is actually foreshadowing
what's to come across all sectors in the
chinese digital economy in ways that
could potentially impact all companies